It wasn't until late in the first season of
NCIS: New Orleans that viewers met ATF agent
Sonja Percy, played by Tony-nominated actress
Shalita Grant.
Once she became a regular on the show in season
two, she quickly became a favorite thanks
to her penchant for calling out BS and her
great chemistry with Agent Christopher LaSalle,
played by Lucas Black.
As anybody who watches network crime procedurals
will tell you, all good things must come to
an end, and no NCIS agent is forever.
After three seasons on the show, Grant decided
to hand in her badge, and the character of
Agent Percy was retired.
Any time an actor leaves a hit show, it always
raises the question: was their ouster a natural
progression of the story, or was something
going on behind the scenes?
"Coming in with some attitude.
Let me lighten that load for you."
"Hate to spoil the party, but we gotta talk."
Throughout the fourth season of the show,
it was clear to the NCIS: New Orleans team
that something was eating at Agent Percy.
She seemed restless and distracted, and made
a few bad calls that were out of character.
In her penultimate episode on the show, "Welcome
to the Jungle," Percy revealed that she interviewed
for a position with the FBI.
Her issues, it seems, were caused by a nagging
feeling that she needed to move on to something
new.
Although she was offered the FBI job, Percy
initially declined it, as she didn't want
to upset her NCIS squadmates.
In Percy's final episode, "High Stakes," she
and Agent LaSalle were assigned to work a
sting operation at a poker game.
Percy ended up in an SUV with the perp they
were tracking and, in a split-second decision,
she rolled the vehicle to prevent him from
getting the upper hand on her.
It was a very risky move that ended up paying
off, but it was further proof that Percy's
instincts were being affected by her feeling
of restlessness.
In the end, Percy realized that the only reason
she turned down the FBI job was to avoid disappointing
other people, which wasn't the correct decision
to make for herself.
At the end of the episode, she announced her
departure from the team.
When Variety originally reported on Grant's
decision to leave, they cited sources who
said:
"The departure is amicable, and mutually agreed
upon between the actress and the producers."
In a later report on Deadline, the actress
herself claimed she was ready to move on.
The year after exiting the show, Grant landed
a recurring role on the final season of Santa
Clarita Diet.
"Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Special Agent Tess Rogers with the FBI."
In 2017, while Grant was still on NCIS: New
Orleans, she did open up about the difficulties
of transitioning from theater to the world
of primetime crime dramas.
In an interview with Lenny Letter, Grant said:
"I didn't realize just how different a procedural
is [...] I do come from theater, and I am
always looking for ways to be human and be
alive and in the moment.
It is challenging to do that with a procedural."
She's far from the first actor to speak up
about the grind of filming twenty-two episode
seasons.
Although she didn't cite those particular
issues when speaking about her exit, it seems
likely that they played a role in her decision
to move on to different projects.
One of those different projects may also shine
some light on what factors motivated her to
leave the show.
It wasn't just her role on Santa Clarita Diet
that kept Grant busy after she left NCIS:
New Orleans.
The enterprising actress launched a hair care
line specifically for black women with Type
4 hair called Four Naturals.
On the company's website, Grant opened up
about what inspired her to launch her haircare
line.
She said:
"I found myself utterly wrecked after three
years on a television show that decimated
my natural hair and my self-image [...] My
tight Type 4 hair was not welcome; instead,
the producers and hair department had no issue
with my natural hair suffering or falling
out to comply with the mandate to wear a ponytail
with little to no curl.
After quitting what was once a dream job,
I told myself that I would turn that pain
into a platform."
Although she didn't specify which show caused
the damage, NCIS: New Orleans is the actress'
only three-year-long stint on any series.
It seems likely that it's the culprit, and
it seems this difficult environment could
be another reason Grant decided to leave.
"I'm gonna miss you city mouse."
"I'll miss you too country mouse."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.